"Who are you?" "Who am I? If I knew the answer to that I wouldn’t be wearing a mask."
there are people believe this world
is fair and good it's all lollipops and
rainbows
we don't do lollipops and rainbows we
know those are pretty colors that just
hide what the world really is black and
white soon they'll shout save us
and we will whisper no
we convinced ourselves that they were
gone but they were just hibernating
they came for everybody,
all police
coordinated simultaneous attacks at the
homes of Tulsa PD until the cops hide
their faces and now the bad guys don't
know where they live and who doesn't
want a secret identity
people who wear masks are dangerous we
should be scared of them because they're
hiding something
Laurie Blake FBI you know how you can
tell the difference between a masked cop
and a vigilante no me neither
they were the vast and insidious
conspiracy
at play If I told you about it your head would explode
who are you?
maybe, uh... I'm Dr. Manhattan
he lives on fucking Mars you curse too
much
oh shit
nothing. ever. ends.
It's only just begun.
Hey guys, Pete here. Today I'm gonna do a
breakdown of the new Watchmen on HBO
trailer that they dropped at Comic Con
this weekend.  like most fans I had been
waiting patiently for this in
coordination with the Twitter campaign
and I have to say, wow. I had high
expectations for this and my initial
reaction is that they exceeded them. we
also got a release date for season 1 at
least that we know now that Watchmen
will premiere in October. I'm going to
forego any attempt at looking at this as
a straight scene-by-scene breakdown
because it's a three minute long trailer
that's packed with Easter eggs instead
I'll look at all the major stuff and the
high points and possibly make some more
detailed videos sometime this week where
I look at it a little bit closer. this
video will contain spoilers about the
ending of the source material the
original comic book series Watchmen so
if you're planning on reading that I
would come back after you finished doing
it  before you watch this video
because it's gonna get spoiled otherwise
with that out of the way let's get into
it
the biggest takeaway about the new
Watchmen trailer is that they seem to
provide a lot of answers to the
questions we had after the initial
teaser came out a couple months ago I
was pretty surprised that we found out
that Jean Smart's character is in fact
Silk Spectre, Don Johnson's character
looks like he's almost definitely
Nite Owl/Dan Dreiberg, and also
Dr. Manhattan will in fact make an
appearance and on top of that it looks
like he'll be returning to Earth. these
were all theories that were kicking
around after the first look video and
there you go we have some answers the
nice part about the fact that they're
giving us answers is that we get a
feeling that there's a much deeper story
under the surface that we can start to
focus on so I'm excited. the trailer
opens with the TV show inside the TV
show similar to how the Tales of the Black Freighter
was a comic inside The Watchmen comic it
appears that American Heroes Story:
Minutemen is a fictional show about the
Minutemen that's inside of the Watchmen
TV show in that we see a robbery taking
place in the 1940s era and see the
costume adventurer Hooded Justice
arrive on the scene the clerk says who
are you and he replies who am i if I
knew the answer to that I wouldn't be
wearing a mask the new character Looking
Glass takes notice of this as he's
eating what looks like being straight
out of the
can Rorschach style I can't lay out the
whole backstory here but the Minutemen
where a group made up of masked
adventurers that predate the Watchmen
comic by 40 plus years Hooded Justice
was the first guy to put on a mask and
fight crime
which inspired others to follow his lead
and do the same this phenomenon changed
things and is where the alternate
reality of the Watchmen universe
diverges from our world the show
existing is the first of many reminders
that even though it looks like our world
the Watchmen universe has definitely
developed differently than ours has
after Hooded Justice's corny line and
Looking Glass' what am I doing with my
life reaction we get our first
introduction to Angela Abraham she says
there are people that believe this world
is fair and good it's all lollipops and
rainbows
we don't do lollipops and rainbows we
know those are pretty colors that just
hide what the world really is black and
white she's talking to a child who is
unnamed at this point we see some family
photos in the background but they don't
seem to be related to anyone else we see
in the trailer so I don't know who this
girl is this conversation jumped out at
me ABB's I was rewatching in that from
what we've seen Angela is who we expect
to be the closest thing to a good guy in
this story but her way of thinking here
sounds very similar to Rorschach rigid
inflexible black-and-white thinking and
the trailer cuts directly to our
modern-day Rorschach's for the next part
of the dialogue who was a nod to the
opening of the comic books say soon they
will shout save us and we will whisper
know so if there's any question as to
whether Rorschach's journal was printed
or not this seems to confirm it of
course the existence of this Rorschach
cult made that pretty clear anyways but
now they seem to be paraphrasing the
journal if not quoting from it from
there we get a little more information
about how the Rorschachs are waging war
against the police we hear Chief Judd
Crawford addressing the police again we
convinced ourselves they were gone but
they were just hibernating we see those
guys preparing to do battle
he continues they came for everybody all
police there's a nice overhead shot here
where we see that there are quite a few
plain clothes costumed adventurers on the
police force alongside the masked the
uniformed cops we see Angela at home
it's a husband Cal and we see the
Rorschachs mount an attack
on them she looks to hold her own
against them but the real implication
here is that they know her identity and
know where she lives to go along with
that we hear another voice continue
coordinated simultaneous attacks at the
homes of Tulsa PD so the cops hide their
faces and now the bad guys don't know
where they live and who doesn't want a
secret identity there's a sequence with
Angela at a school where we see that
Robert Redford is the current president
in the Watchmen universe which is a
direct callback to the book and a nod to
the comedian's pin made out of eggs a la
Angela we get a closer look at the
cemetery scene from the other trailer
and what stands out here is that this
looks like a funeral of someone
important rather than just any police
officer we caught a glimpse of a
newspaper saying Ozymandias aka Adrian
Veidt was officially declared dead but I
don't think this is his funeral because
well I think it seems a little bit fishy
that they would actually kill him off we
see Veidt throughout this trailer and
it's noticeable that he has a cake with
one candle that he's blowing out I'm
thinking he might be celebrating the
first year of his new life or one year
in hiding or on the run or something
along those lines if you look at the
wording on the newspaper article it says
he's been officially declared dead not
that he was found dead or that he was
murdered so I don't know I don't think
it's likely that he's actually gonna die
but let me know what you think about
that the next bit of voiceover says
people who wear masks are dangerous we
should be scared of them a little girl
says why and the reply is because
they're hiding something if you look at
the closed captioning here it says that
this is Cal Abraham but it's a different
actor as far as I can tell and I have no
idea who these people are what's going
on as a result of that it's interesting
though that he's pointing out that
wearing a mask is something that you do
to hide who you are throughout this part
of the trailer we see a bus going down
with lots of criminals in a warehouse
there are plenty of costume adventurer
police on the scene and so is Special
Agent Blake with pirate Jenny who we saw
in the first trailer at her side we also
get a look at where those screens that
were surrounding Looking Glass came from
it appears as if police do
interrogations in this pod or this room
whatever you want to call it but there's
no
details about what exactly is going on
here we see the scene where Angela
attacks the guy in the camper again
there's a quick glimpse of the newspaper
that says president Redford won't be
seeking re-election and then we get
introductions between laurie blake and
angela at the cemetery this is where you
realize that Laurie took her biological
father the Comedian's last name and that
this character is in fact Silk Spectre -
from the comment she says do you know
how you can tell the difference between
a masked cop and a vigilante Angela
answer's no and she says me neither this
is a very interesting dynamic and I
suppose we're gonna see that play out
throughout the series after that we meet
Louis Gossett jr. character we aren't
sure who he is at this point but he has
some sort of spotlight gadget with him
we see Angela approaching him outside
and we hear the voiceover of his voice
say there's a vast and insidious
conspiracy at play if I told you about
it your head would explode
Angela cuts in to say who are you and he
replies maybe I'm dr. Manhattan Angela
points out that he lives on fucking Mars
and Louis Gossett jr. replies that she
curses too much there are two scenes
going on here between these characters
that are tied together and in the
background we watch a sequence of images
while he's talking we watch looking
glass pulling on his mask
Ozymandias on horseback riding past the
pirate flag again Laurie walking away
from the dr. Manhattan looking booth
that they had at comic-con
perhaps she was making a call to her
ex-boyfriend dr. Manhattan and another
shot of the incident at the carnival
with all the bodies laying around on the
ground there's two other images squeezed
in here that catch your eye as being out
of place one looks like a camp site that
could be from some time in the distant
past there's a man on the ground that
looks like he's been killed and the
second one has a bunch of people
crowding around with smoke in the air
then we get our first glimpse of dr.
Manhattan on Mars through a satellite
feed David Bowie's song life on Mars
kicks in and then things take off dr.
Manhattan brings down a castle looking
structure he'd built that seems to be
made of dust we cut back to earth and
get a glimpse of Archie the Nite Owl
2's airship flying through the air
angela is exactly me when she looks up
and says oh shit we get the idea that
Don Johnson's
character is probably an older dan
dreiberg AKA Nite Owl from the comic
he uses Archie's flamethrower to take
out a drone over the farmhouse we saw in
the first trailer and I say he's
probably night out too because he also
crashed his Archie so it's not clear if
he knows what he's doing here or not it
could be that he hasn't flown it for
quite a long time and he doesn't have
the hang of it anymore or it could be
that chief Crawford borrowed Archie off
the actual night owl I'm leaning towards
it actually being him but we'll have to
wait and see either way we see a lot of
fighting going down in different
locations with cops
Rorschacs masked adventurers and some
civilians at a trailer park that it's
called Nixonville there's a courtroom
scene that looks like they're trying
Ozymandias for a squid attack on new
york at the end of the book we see an
illustration of the squid the judge is
wearing a mask and the court officers
are all wearing wigs and robes so it
doesn't look like the US court system in
our world anyway we see car crashes
Archie crashing Adrian pushing his
plunger an explosion in the street that
could be from American Hero story Minute
Men since it looks like it's in the 40s
and we have Ozymandias with a voiceover
who says nothing ever ends it's only
just begun we watch as Laurie is in a
faceoff with a costumed adventurer who seems to be on the wrong side of the law
his costume almost looks like an updated
Nite Owl get up and we see her shoot
him as he tries to escape a pack of pigs
break into the courtroom as Ozy is
talking and we see Angela and the
unnamed child she's with in all these
scenes sitting in a car as Tiny squid's
rain down from the sky the music winds
down with the shot as the voice-over
finishes and he has a very satisfied
look on his face which definitely makes
me think that he's up to something
even though the newspapers are reporting
that he's dead there's something else
going on the title pops up after that
and then we watch as dr. Manhattan walks
down the street and picks up a mask that
looks like his face we see the blue hand
so we know it's him and it definitely
looks like he'll be making an appearance
at some point in this season it's not
clear when he was on Mars it certainly
looked like he was glowing here it
doesn't look like that but I
and say that that means it's not him I
definitely think this is dr. Manhattan
and he's going to come back to the story
so the trailer ends there and I did have
to cut a lot of stuff out but I think I
hit all the high points I'm very curious
as to whether chief Crawford is in fact
the Nite Owl we know from the casting
that he's got a wife so it's clear that
he's not with laurie anymore
he lives in Tulsa she comes in from the
FBI so they're all in the same place
also very curious to find out what Louis
Gossett jr. role is in all of this I
think this thing looks fantastic I was
really looking forward to it it seems to
tick all the boxes of the things I was
hoping they would get into I'm super
curious to see what you guys think in
the comments there's a ton of new
characters here most of them aren't
named I think this guy we know his name
is Red Scare I think he's the only one
whose name we actually know from the
casting announcements but there's
definitely a lot going on they
definitely are making a lot of
references back to the original work
which is very exciting they seem to be
doing it in the right way rather than
making it too on-the-nose too
straightforward they're doing their own
thing but they're paying homage at the
same time and I think that's going to be
fantastic
but let me know what you think please
like the video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already follow along I'll be doing
plenty of watchman videos in the lead up
to October and I will definitely be
doing weekly videos when the shows on
the air thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon